[Music]  what's the last thing you remember Danny  he said we had to write the reason you  survived it's because you're a very  uncommon girl you're not alone not  anymore  do you know a mutants or would anyone  like to she had their first time brain I  was 13 I thought it was a dream I just  lost control Sam I started panicking  people got hurt Roberto my girlfriend a  partner Ariana I killed 18 men one by  [Music]  this isn't a hospital at the cage  it's important we find out here power so  we can help you get better I saw  something  I don't think she wanted me to see  [Music]  I don't think we're here to cut better  this place takes your greatest fear it  makes you live through it until it kills  you is there we can get out of this  together  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]